[Music]
this month Disney released a trailer for
their new live-action version of The
Little Mermaid starring a black actress
and some yeah
me too I loved it but some people got
very mad and before that the Lord of the
Rings spin-off featured a black Hobbit
and some people got very very mad so why
are people getting mad at mermaids and
Hobbits well I'll tell you in a segment
called how did we get here
a few weeks ago Disney released their
first trailer for the upcoming
live-action Little Mermaid movie
starring actress Hallie Bailey some
people reacted to it like this
she's like me
they need a black Ariel
what it sounds like me yeah she's brown
like you
we're gonna go see it when it comes down
to the theater yeah
like this scientific perspective
okay it doesn't make a lot of sense to
have someone with darker skin who lives
deep in the ocean I mean if anything I
mean not only should The Little Mermaid
be pale she should actually be
translucent if you're not gonna take
this seriously then we're not going to
and we're just gonna troll the hell out
of you at this point I say we make a
couple of other Classics this time using
an all-white cast
I say we remake roots
[Applause]
my friends call me Toby
it's ridiculous to be mad that Ariel is
black there's only one good reason to be
mad at Ariel and that's the fact that
she is constantly bragging about all her
thingamabobs oh really you got 20. well
Ariel some people don't have a single
thingamabob so check you're thinking
about privilege
but
but it turns out there's a reason why
people are so mad about The Little
Mermaid it's because of something called
the empathy gap which sounds like a
shitty new store at the mall
but it's actually the scientific concept
that people have a harder time relating
to someone who doesn't look like them
and when it comes to entertainment the
empathy Gap means that a lot of white
people don't want to see movies starring
people of color there's even research to
back it up a study from the Journal of
communication says that in romantic
movies white people showed quote
significantly less interest in seeing
movies with mostly black casts than in
seeing movies with mostly white casts
which is crazy because if you didn't
watch movies with black casts then
you're missing the single greatest
cinematic moment of all time which of
course is this
all right
unfortunately the research gets even
worse one study found that when white
people watched videos of non-white
people their brains registered as little
activity as when they watched a blank
screen
I know mint which means when I do this
white viewers can't see me
[Applause]
this isn't all on white people it turns
out the empathy Gap doesn't go just one
way we all want to see ourselves on
screen so as long as there is diversity
in who decides what movies and TV shows
get made we should be fine right but
that's the thing as of 2020 in digital
and broadcast TV only 10 percent of show
creators were minorities and 92 percent
of all chair and CEO jobs were held by
white people 92 percent do you know how
white that is that's whiter than pumpkin
spice latte deodorant and
this is a real product and if I have to
know about it so do you
the problem is all those white
Executives aren't immune to the empathy
Gap they want to see people who look
like them so they end up green lighting
shows that look like this or like this
white people
if it feels weird to you to have a black
mermaid imagine how weird this felt to
us it's a show about a bunch of white
people who live in New York who still
manage to have fun in a coffee shop even
though every single person of color had
been purged from New York City at least
that's what I assumed friends was about
I would not know I only watched the
prequel so
we all know the problem right the
problem is an entertainment industry run
by white people who want to see
themselves on TV and viewers who believe
a lady can have a fin for a butt but not
melanin so
it's the solution well believe it or not
it comes back to this see even though it
makes the world's dumbest people Furious
casting a talented gorgeous black girl
as Ariel is exactly how we get through
this because just seeing different kinds
of people on screen helps empathy grow
one recent study showed that exposing
white people to Black Faces increased
white participants subsequent liking for
a different set of Black Faces so
basically black Ariel is going to help
people get excited about black Bale or
black Sleeping Beauty or most
importantly black Captain Crunch
and frankly the sooner we get a
live-action version of that the better
by the way having diverse casts isn't
just the right thing to do it's also
good for business one study showed that
employing multiple black actors in the
principal cast achieved significantly
higher domestic box office revenues and
I know that that sounds a little
confusing because didn't I just say that
white people don't want to see diverse
movies well here's the thing and I know
this is going to be hard for some people
to hear but white people aren't the only
people
so even if white people might be less
excited about a movie people of color
turn out and more than make up for it so
those white executives are going to have
to catch up and we're going to have to
start promoting people of color not
because they're woke a word you totally
ruined but because people want to see
shows like squid game or a black lady
sketch show or the Amber Ruffin show
and
white people you can help a recent study
says the drop in interest in seeing a
movie with a black cast was erased when
White's read positive comments about the
film from other whites so white people
if you can even see me go see black
movies and then tell your friends about
them I tell them myself but I'm just a
blank screen
now I know that making a bunch of movies
with black people in them isn't going to
cure racism but [ __ ] it ain't nothing
it's a start and if we can do that then
we can finally focus on what really
matters making sure every single person
in this great country of ours has their
fair share of thingamabobs this has been
how did we get here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]